Speaker 1: One of my favorite media stories
that's going on right now is that the more
extreme than Fox News right wing media, they
smell blood in the water.
They are starting to sense fox news may be
bailing on donald trump.
Now they haven't bailed on Trump to be very
clear.
Fox News is still sucking up to Trump.
And I'm going to give you some examples in
a moment.
But one of the things that is happening in
the lead up, not not to the 2022 midterms,
but to the 2024 Republican primary is FOX
News wants an off ramp.
Fox News wants to credibly be able to get
behind someone other than Donald Trump.
If that is how the winds turn and that person
seems to be Ron DeSantis.
But Fox isn't abandoning Trump right now.
They're just starting to play up alternatives
to Trump, including Ron DeSantis.
But the other media outlets that want to dethrone
Fox News as the primary or most important
right wing media outlet.
They smell blood in the water and they're
going after Fox News.
Here is Greg Kelly on newsmax accusing fox
news of trying to cancel Donald Trump.
This is good for the left.
There's very little that's good for the left
right now.
But right wing media going after each other.
I'll take whatever we can get.
Speaker 3: Tone it down a notch, Mr. Vice
President.
Nice guy.
I like lots of things about him.
But not everything.
And not January six and not this.
I think he's kind of faking it just a little
bit.
All right.
So they bang the gong.
Fox News alert for Mike Pence.
Donald Trump spoke at 3 p.m..
What happened then?
Speaker 2: It's a very important issue.
And a lot of Republicans believe that they
don't like the covered voting rules that are
in place, and they will.
Speaker 3: While Donald Trump was speaking
at a major event in Washington, D.C., the
first time he went back to Washington since
he left the presidency, they had a bunch of
people doing this.
Speaker 1: How dare they not cover Trump's
big speech?
Speaker 3: No, Donald Trump again, it's between
the billionaires.
It's personal and there's something personal.
And I don't like it.
I don't think it's fair to Donald Trump.
They're trying to cancel him.
Actually, you know, I knew the left wing was
trying to cancel him, but the conservative
media as well.
Check this out.
Newsmax had the whole thing.
If I renounce my beliefs, if I agree to stay
silent.
Speaker 1: Imagine bragging that you broadcast
this.
Speaker 3: If I stayed at home.
I just took it easy.
Speaker 4: The persecution of Donald Trump
would stop immediately.
It would stop.
But that's not what I will do.
Speaker 3: I can't do that.
All right.
He spoke for about an hour and 40 minutes.
It was fascinating.
It was all good stuff.
We carried it live right here on Newsmax.
But again, Fox News did it.
They're trying to cancel him.
Conservative media tried to cancel the former
president.
Speaker 1: Now, it is not actually true that
Fox News has turned on Trump.
Newsmax benefits from that narrative understand
that Newsmax has a vested interest in convincing
viewers that Fox has turned on Trump because
Newsmax and Fox share a lot of viewers.
And if they are Trumpist viewers and they
start to believe Fox is now anti-Trump, the
only place to get my pro-Trump pablum is on
Newsmax.
It's only good for Newsmax is ratings now.
It's not even really true.
Fox News is setting up an off ramp.
That's all they're doing.
But Trump is furious about it anyway.
The other day, Fox and Friends, we played
this clip.
They simply mentioned poll numbers and Trump
lost it.
Speaker 3: You got people from all across
the country convening in Tampa.
I am thinking about that is a little different
than a couple of other polls that we've seen
over the last couple of weeks.
Two weeks ago in Florida, Blue Point, rather,
blueprint polling did a poll.
DeSantis leads the former president in all
age groupings.
Then there was a University of New Hampshire
poll in June to says that DeSantis actually
led Trump 39 to 37 and that New York Times
Siena College poll that we incited quite a
few times, less than half of Republican voters
backed Donald Trump as their preferred choice.
So it's like the young people who are activists
at that event, right.
Like the former president.
But looking at these other polls, different
answer.
Yeah, we look state by state.
Ron DeSantis is showing tremendous strength
in New Hampshire, Michigan and Florida.
He's leading or tied with the former president
and turning point run by Charlie Kirk.
Extremely impressive organization and they
are extremely enthusiastic and active.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So they just read poll numbers.
That's all they did.
And Trump flipped out.
Trump immediately went on truth social and
said, Fox and Friends just really botched
my poll numbers, no doubt on purpose.
That show has been terrible.
Going to the dark side, they quickly vote
the big turning point poll.
They quickly quote the big turning point poll
victory of almost 60 points over the number
two Republican and then hammer me with outliers.
Actually, almost all polls have me reading
leading all Republicans and Biden by a lot.
Reno.
Paul Ryan, one of the weakest and worst speakers
ever, must be running the place anyway.
Thank you to turning point.
The crowd and love was amazing.
That's it was so mild.
So mild.
And if you want proof that they're not really
turning on Trump, just look at this from the
same episode.
Speaker 3: Donald Trump is playing in the
Pro-Am today with Bryson DeChambeau.
And I believe.
Speaker 1: Now they say everybody's wearing
almost the exact same clothes, but it's actually
not the same episode.
I apologize.
Speaker 3: Playing in the Pro-Am today with
Bryson DeChambeau and I believe Dustin Johnson.
I don't know who's going to close out that
he's.
Speaker 2: A scratch golfer.
Speaker 3: He is right.
They're all good golfers.
But I think the other one was the greatest
golfing president ever.
Really athletic.
That's right.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Very, very much a good golfer sucking
up to him.
And then here's another one where now Fox
and Friends is on the defensive.
They talk about poll numbers, but then they
remember to say we didn't invent the numbers.
Speaker 3: 55% of Republicans or people leaning
Republican want somebody other than Donald
Trump to run.
That's up 6% from their earlier poll.
And if the former president's watching, you
should know those are the just the numbers
you're relaying.
You didn't come up with those numbers.
CNN came up with it.
Ainslie said this was a fascinating poll.
It is.
That's why we just talked about it now.
Speaker 1: I had to do the same thing.
Remember last week I told you guys that Joe
Biden's approval rating is in the toilet and
people were furious at me for reporting those
numbers.
I actually hilariously had to do the same
disclaimer where I was like, Guys, I didn't
do the polling.
It's not reflective of my opinion.
Speaker 3: And they are right as often as
Haley's Comet comes by every seven years.
So you're just saying all we talked about
for the last 4 minutes is not accurate?
I'm just saying that Donald Trump is watching
and seeing if Donald Trump is watching, just
let him know.
We didn't come up with that number.
That's what the poll said, right?
Absolutely.
Speaker 1: They're treating him like a little
kid.
It's amazing.
Actually, I.
Speaker 3: Was talking to him.
Yeah, I was talking to a pollster about these
numbers.
And they seem to be across the board regarding
so few people on the Democratic Party, one
just too.
Speaker 2: Soon to tell.
There are so many different polls and they
all say different.
Right.
Which party of the Democrats, they.
Speaker 1: Are stumbling all over themselves
to avoid angering Donald Trump.
So listen, Fox News hasn't fully turned on
Trump.
Fox News is setting up an off ramp.
That's what they're doing.
And Newsmax is trying to take advantage of
it.
This is the power struggle happening right
now within right wing media.
I care about it to the extent that maybe it's
bad for Republicans, that would be great